[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday I was
using cinema jigs as a pillow Haigh like
a lot of people in nerdfighteria I'm
tired because the project for awesome
was this weekend and it was awesome and
fatiguing first tank the numbers in the
last 48 hours the foundation to decrease
worldsuck raise $75,000 we did this in a
number of ways people donate it directly
at projectforawesome.com I'm taking off
my jacket because I'm inside and that's
weird people also bought things at
dftba.com like for instance your Hank or
fishes and my new zombie apocalypse
story a sequel to zombie corns but the
project for awesome raised even more
money because Alex Day is donating the
proceeds from remixes of Forever Yours
to charity that's going to be at least
$15,000 by the way get your forever
yours and your Forever Yours remixes
there are links in the doobly-doo also
there are a lot of other successful
projects like iJustine x' project to get
Wells built in the developing world and
Rosie raising money for the Stroke
Association and when you add it all up
it's more than $100,000 and you can
still donate a project for awesome com
or by buying my new zombie apocalypse
story for the next two days there's more
info in the doobly-doo and of course the
project for awesome generated thousands
of videos about charities millions of
views tens of thousands of tweets
hundreds of thousands of comments and to
fulfill a challenge you released this
picture of yourself as an eight-year-old
which nerdfighteria because it is
awesome then began to remix let's see
some of those remixes yes yes more yes I
love it I love the remixes but I got to
say the highlight of p4a this year for
me was when I covered my face and
sharpie when we reached $50,000 and then
immediately thereafter someone rang my
doorbell and I panicked because I'm not
trying to be the guy in the neighborhood
with the Sharpie face so I just hid this
was the most fun I've had at the project
for awesome since 2007 and I just I was
great
yay and remember you can still donate
the foundation will be distributing this
money based on how we as a community
decided it should be distributed which
I'm really excited about you'll see more
about that in the coming weeks
in other news Hank there are updates on
the torta nerdfighting and the
doobly-doo including that shows in
Vancouver
Boston New York Portland and Raleigh are
sold out sorry those places there are
still tickets in lots of cities and
nerdfighters even if you don't see us on
tour you might still see us on tour
because this is what our van looks like
Hank I'd like to thank my publisher
penguin for giving you such a
hilariously small billing it brings me a
lot of joy so Hank that's our van the
father stars comes out in three weeks
I'm trying not to freak out but I'm not
succeeding I have to go right now
because I have to write crossword clues
for the crossword puzzle that's going to
be in the Tour de nerdfighting program
so people have something to do while
they stand in line but I did make a play
with ten of my favorite project for
awesome videos which you can watch now
by clicking on my head I think I have to
say that you're a project for awesome
video about the well that nerdfighter I
built in Haiti was pretty amazing it
reminded me how lucky we are to be part
of the nerdfighter community and also
how lucky I am to be your brother
ladies Hank I'll see you on Wednesday
again click here for the playlist best
wishes